hi I'm bill patzert I spent more than 50
years at NASA's Jet Propulsion
Laboratory studying climate change and
global warming much of what the public
really knows about climate change and
global warming comes from Hollywood
today we're going to dissect a few films
and see where Hollywood gets it right
and wrong day after tomorrow
global warming has melted the polar ice
cap
do not act soon it is our children and
our grandchildren who will have to pay
the price but they got the science wrong
what we saw in New York City the oceans
rise it's exceptionally photogenic but
the size is totally unrealistic it's too
immediate global warming gets you slowly
this instantaneous switch into a mini
ice age over a few days the timescale is
all wrong we're not cooling we're
warming the scientists played by Dennis
Quaid dramatically draws the line across
the center of the United States
everyone south of that line it's not the
way it happens but there are a lot of
things I liked about it a couple of
ironic things one of them is mass
migration out of the United States there
will be mass migrations as we look into
the 21st century and particularly in the
American Southwest now one of the things
they really got wrong is one of the
least likely places in the world to have
devastating tornadoes is Southern
California day after tomorrow they
played for the camera not for the
science
let's give it a c-minus our next film is
2012 massive solar eruption impacts the
core of the earth setting off a geologic
catastrophe in the crust essentially
destroying civilization it's definitely
a dud global warming has almost no
impact on the Earth's crust it's a
surface manifestation these are two
different animals San Andreas Fault is
shifting here in California one of the
big forces of nature that hangs over all
our heads here is the San Andreas Fault
it's moving it's powerful and
potentially very destructive but it's
totally decoupled from climate change on
a popcorn scale we're going to give it
an April
but on a science scale it's a d-minus
interstellar really asks the core
question as population explodes as we
change our climate as we devastate our
ecosystems what is the future of mankind
on planet Earth and it's interesting how
they use the past as a metaphor for the
future expanding droughts you didn't
expect this dirt that was giving you
this food to turn on you like that and
destroy you
starvation on a mass scale we ran out of
food the world needs farmers good
farmers nelson's Torchy's whole crop
they're saying it's the last harvest for
okra ever the thing that really gets you
is not sea-level rise it's the lack of
water and the lack of food due to
overpopulation but six billion people
just try to imagine that and every last
one of them trying to have it all how
does the human race deal with that and
if we don't want a repeat of the excess
and wastefulness of the 20th century
then we need to teach our kids about
this planet we're not meant to save the
world
we're meant to leave it
[Music]
there's not a planet in our solar system
that can sustain life or any nearby
solar system big question great flick
and a plus man max
although it paints a grim picture of a
post-apocalyptic future there's
something very contemporary about it
[Applause]
resource essentially that sustains
civilization which is water is being
controlled by a megalomaniac who is
misogynistic totally lacking in empathy
for the people that he rules there is
something really prophetic about Mad Max
we see the rise of dictators cross the
planet and resources become more and
more limited most of the earth has
turned into a desert now we're seeing
that on a smaller scale today I'm giving
this movie an A+ on many levels myself
I'd go back and look at this many many
times I think the message from all these
movies we have to be careful who we vote
for we have to renew ourselves off
fossil fuels and onto renewable energies
this is the home planet there is no
planet B
[Music]
[Music]